سترى هذا التأكيد العظيم للعمل
الذي من المفترض أن تكون في السرير حبيبي ،
حان وقت النوم عزيزي ، أعود إلى
السرير ،
سآتي وأراك في غضون دقيقة ، حسنًا ،
آسف الجميع ،
نعم  ستأخذك المربية إلى السرير ،
شكرًا نانا
حسنًا ، لقد كان وقت النوم فاشلًا ، أليس كذلك
آسف الجميع اعتقدت أن هذه
لحظة سأقوم بها على الفيسبوك مباشرة ، نحن لطيفون
وآمنون هل يسأل أي شخص ما إذا كان الأطفال يهربون مثل
ثلاث أربع مرات  بعد وقت النوم ،
لحسن الحظ أمي هنا حتى
تتمكن من المساعدة هناك ،
حسنًا ، أين كنا مجموعة مختلفة جدًا
من الظروف في الوقت الحالي
، ولهذا السبب لا يزال لدينا هذه
القيود هناك ومرة أخرى تستند إل
النصائح الصحية أو
،  هل أنا آسف يا عزيزي ، لقد استغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً حسنًا ، أنا آسف للجميع
، سأذهب وأعيد الإجازة إلى الفراش ،
لأن هذا مضى وقتًا طويلاً على وقت
نومها ، شكرًا لانضمامك إلي ، أعتقد أنني
غطيت كل شيء  كنت أرغب في
المشاركة في هذه المرحلة على أي حال ولكن ربما
سأقفز عبر الإنترنت  أو نسخة موسعة
نسخة ممتدة غير منقطعة
[موسيقى]